[Musique]
c'est désormais une habitude avec la
présidence d' emmanuel macron à chaque
fois qu'il y à un nouveau sujet sur la
table il y à une nouvelle approche une
nouvelle méthode mais les résultats vont
ils suivre bonsoir à tous et bienvenue
dans ce nouveau numéro du 7 8 le débat
ce soir discussions autour des banlieues
pas de nouveaux plans pour les quartiers
défavorisés donc mais une nouvelle
approche alors que les acteurs de la
politique de la ville étaient remplis
d'espoir après la remise du plan borloo
certains sont déçus après les annonces
récentes du présidence du président des
annonces il n'y en a pas eu beaucoup
d'ailleurs beaucoup sont remises au mois
de juillet alors faut-il croire en la
méthode du président de la république at
il raison de ne pas annoncer de plan
spécial pour les quartiers les plus
fragiles de la république pour répondre
à ces questions et à beaucoup d'autres
deux mâles blancs sont en plateau didier
baichère député de la république en
marge de la première circonscription des
yvelines
clément ortega directeur de cabinet de
la verrière et une femme aussi avec nous
maryse bresson enseignante chercheur en
sociologie à l'ulb est ce que
l'université de versailles
saint-quentin-en-yvelines bonsoir à tous
les trois je précise tout de suite que
ne sont pas les propos polémiques
c'était pour faire référence à
l'expression utilisée par le président
lors de la présentation de ce plan fin
pas plan on peut pas citer ainsi sur les
banlieues maryse besson je me tourne
vers vous qui vous serez peut être
beaucoup plus objectif sur ce sur ces
annonces puisque vous êtes enseignant
chercheur à l'ehess cure sociologie le
président de la république at-il raison
avec le recul de ces deux dernières
semaines de ne pas annoncer un nouveau
plan pour les quartiers les plus
fragiles de la république et de faire
faire confiance on va dire de partir du
bail de faire confiance aux acteurs
locaux pour pour pour les banlieues on a
toujours du mal
dire il a raison il a tort mais quand
même là il faut avouer qu'on voit pas
bien entre guillemets quelle est la
ligne et donc non non je pense pas
qu'ils aient raison parce que en tout
cas il y avait un signal qui était
attendu il ya aussi une solidarité où
une manifestation de solidarité qui est
forcément attendu par rapport aux
quartiers et qui n'a pas été perçu comme
tel donc sur ce plan là pour tous ceux
qui s'intéressent à ces questions
c'était plutôt l'étonnement et la
déception je pense donc ça c'est enfin
objectivement il me semble que c'est la
réaction qui a été très très majoritaire
clément ortega pour la verrière qu'en
est-il vous n'êtes pas vous non plus
convaincu par cette nouvelle méthode de
dire que ce qui a été fait pendant 40
ans ne marche pas et les résultats ne
sont pas forcément enfin donne raison au
président vous je je je trouve pas déjà
je fais pas du tout le même bilan que le
président dira que les plans successifs
n'ont pas marché qu'il n'ait pas abouti
parce que la politique de la ville c'est
donner plus à ceux qui ont un afin de
pouvoir rétablir sur le territoire et de
la république une égalité pour tout le
monde
or oui on peut dire que il y a encore
des grosses poches de pauvreté des
quartiers qui sont toujours des
quartiers prioritaires on a toujours
besoin de la politique de la ville ça je
peux lui donner raison mais dire que les
plans successifs n'ont rien donné je
crois qu'il n'a pas conscience de ce qu
aurait été des quartiers est ce
qu'aurait été la france si ces plans
dame n'avait pas n'avaient pas été mis à
votre ville par exemple aussi vous
pouvez tirer le même le même conclusion
sur la ville de la verrière ces trois
quarts de la population aujourd'hui qui
est qui profitent de la politique de la
ville on est les trois quarts de la
ville sont effectivement en quartiers
prioritaires
budgétairement vu les restrictions
budgétaires des dotations globales de
fonctionnement c'est-à-dire les
dotations donné par l'état comme à
toutes les villes comme elles sont en
diminution nous sommes obligés de vivre
et de faire ce qu'on appelle notre droit
commun avec les financements de la
politique de la ville parce que nous
sommes profondément une ville concernée
par par la politique de la ville et donc
là on avait effectivement un essai
et et la préfecture et les agents
territoriaux de l'état nous disait vous
allez voir il ya un plan qui va être
ambitieux quand on regarde le plan n'est
absolument pas ambitieux mais c'est même
plus profondément on est en train de
remettre en cause une des valeurs
essentielles de la république qui est
l'accès au droit
les mêmes droits pour tous alors on va
faire réagir didier baichère en qualité
de député et les oem vous êtes forcément
le défenseur ici de la politique portée
par le par le président
c'est vrai qu'on peut s'interroger un
peu sur sur la méthode mine de rien
puisque huit mois de discussions avec
jean louis borloo qui a mobilisé
beaucoup de monde et puis finalement
nous dit baye aura rien ou presque rien
oui ça c'est un point de vue
bon après c'est vrai qu'on a on a été
habitué en fait avoir des chiffres très
importants et on distribue de l'argent à
toulon devant borloo soit 48 milliards
d'euros en plus enfin j'attends quand on
regarde ce qu'il ya dans le plan borloo
il ya probablement beaucoup de choses
qui seront reprises à un moment donné
mais c'est vrai que là la somme d'argent
à un moment donné et donne un petit peu
le vertige et la méthode en fait est
différente on va essayer
systématiquement de partir d'aller vers
le systémique j'ai eu l'occasion une sur
ce plateau de parler d'emploi et en quoi
le territoire est probablement beaucoup
plus compétents pour parler des
expérimentations en matière d'emploi que
faire une grande politique publique pour
les quartiers politique de la ville
maintenant si on regarde les chiffres
manière très concrète
le budget politique de la ville 490
millions il est sécurisé le budget de
l'anru pour la rénovation des quartiers
compliqué il est passé de 4,7 milliards
à 10 milliards
donc l'argent il est là maintenant c'est
effectivement pas forcément ça qu'on a
mis en avant on dit regardons sur les
territoires qu est ce qui passe mettons
les acteurs autour de la table il y
avait besoin de huit mois de réflexion
pour pour dire ça je pense qu'il y avait
besoin de prendre la température est de
voir qu'est ce qui avait été fait c'est
moi j'étais une réunion la semaine
dernière à plaine commune donc c'est pas
sa tante en yvelines donc sur la scène
syndiqués un territoire plaine commune
est probablement le territoire le plus
défavorisé celle en ile de france a un
des plus difficiles
ils sont en train de faire le constat
que par rapport au public ici les les
jeunes en difficulté dans les quartiers
ils ont une telle multitude de
programmes de dispositifs que eux mêmes
les jeunes ceux qui sont concernés mais
savent plus à qui s'adresser et comment
faire et que tu vois simplifiée c'est
pas une question de simplification c'est
qu'il faut commencer recommencer à
mettre les acteurs qui savent autour de
la table l'exemple de l'emploi encore
une fois on en a parlé du plan 1000
jeunes qui concerne cinq ans à saint
quentin en yvelines
si vous mettez pas les entreprises
autour de la table pour parler d'emploi
on n'y arrivera pas si en matière
d'éducation vous commencez pas par
dédoubler les classes de cp
vous pouvez toujours avoir des
incantations mais ça fonctionne pas or
là la première pierre qu'on a posés sur
ce projet de politique de la ville
rénové c'est le dédoublement des classes
de cp tel est le résultat au bout d'un
an tous les professeurs pour vous dire
que c'est une réussite on passe au ce1
et c est ça va s'accélérer à la à la
rentrée prochaine sur sur la position du
gouvernement je vous propose d'écouter
jacques mézard ministre en charge de la
cohésion des territoires c'était deux
jours après le discours du président au
sénat ce que nos concitoyens attendent
ce ne sont pas une accumulation de plan
ce sont des actions des actions il y en
a déjà eu il y en a déjà eu sur l'école
il y en a déjà eu sur les emplois francs
il y en a eu en matière économique
il y en a eu en matière sociale et nous
allons continuer et ce qu'a indiqué le
président de la république indiquant que
dès le mois de juillet un certain nombre
d'opérations seraient mises en place
j'aurai l'occasion de revenir aussi sur
la modification de l'anru sur
l'accélération des dossiers sur les
engagements sur la simplification
eh bien oui aujourd'hui ça ne fonctionne
pas très bien mais ça ne fonctionnement
pas très bien la rue depuis plusieurs
années et nous savons tous pourquoi à
avant d'évoquer l'anru didier deschamps
rapidement on a aussi l'impression avec
ce que disait le ministre à l'instant il
ya eu des actions et on a l'impression
qu'aujourd'hui l'état ne peut pas faire
plus pourquoi le président de la
république ne présente pas comme ça pas
pas forcément les moyens humains
financiers de faire plus pour les
quartiers et que c'est à eux peut-être
d'agir directement
c'est pourquoi je pense que ça se
présente vraiment vraiment pas comme ça
prenons logement puisque on sort de deux
quinze jours est à peu près le même
nombre de nuits sur le sujet du logement
qui a défendu sru bec et ongles pendant
ces quinze jours c'est la majorité
présidentielle beaucoup voulaient faire
des coups de canifs extrêmement
important sur les séries aussi à tous
ici vraiment qui est ce qui va relancer
une politique de logement de rénovation
de logements en essayant de passer de
8000 à 40 mille logements achetés vendus
il ya une volonté par rapport aux
dispositifs existants d'aller beaucoup
plus loin que ce qui est fait
aujourd'hui marquer à sa façon
oui alors moi je comprends pas la
logique mais je dirai simplement je
trouve qu'il ya une passe car nous dit
on va pas multiplier les plans mais par
contre on nous parle de telles mesures
et on nous dit on va partir d'en bas et
de tout ce qui sort dans bas mais il
peut y avoir que des sommes de mesures
qui partent combat justement c'est un le
plan s'est essayé de mettre en musique
et essayer de fixer un cap et là il n'y
a pas de cap on repart d'en bas non mais
on est contraire par rapport à ce que ce
qui vient d'être dit on va être dans une
démultiplication de petites mesures si
j'ai bien compris avec les mêmes
montants et où on va
dir est ce que vous voulez garder sa
repartir ça moi je pense que c'est quand
même ennuyeux qui est pas une vision sur
là où on veut aller ça peut pas partir
d'en bas c'est quand même les quartiers
là où il ya la plus grande concentration
de pauvreté c'est des quartiers
effectivement qui sont dans des
situations extrêmement compliqué à
anvers lesquels il ya une
désolidarisation de des territoires
environnants c'est la république dit pas
on est solidaire de ces quartiers là et
ça va pas des emplois français pour les
tpv le financement des places en crèche
numerus kirti politique de la ville
c'est pour les pv le plan emploi en
quand on peut prendre très concrètement
pour saint quentin le plan pour 1000
jeunes qu'est-ce qui fait il ne remue
multiplient pas par contre il a un
budget d'accompagnement qui est allouée
par la préfecture de la région
ile-de-france pour pouvoir le mener
mais on prend les acteurs qui font et on
les met ensemble donc c'est vraiment
encore une fois en termes de méthode
complètement différent par contre de
l'argent pour accompagner il y en a sur
ces dispositifs et même sur la question
de la méthode moi j'ai un soucis là vous
entendre il y a un an le maire de grigny
lancé états généraux de la politique de
la ville des merdeux alors là pour le
coup en terme des chéquiers politique
on avait tous les airs de hauteur de
droite fait participer les 10 du tube mr
de la verrière qui ne pouvait pas être
là ce soir parce que justement il y à
des actions dans les quartiers
prioritaires il ya une exposition de
peintures et donc elle y est
parce que c'est au jour le jour les élus
de terrain ils sont ce sont des élus qui
se sont retrouvés au moment des états
généraux des acteurs territoriaux des
associatifs des gens de terrain une
année de discussions discussions avec
borloo pour qu'ils puissent faire
proposer ce plan et on arrive le
président fait son discours il n'y a pas
un seul acteur qui est content
aujourd'hui aucun acteur qui a participé
au plan borloo est aujourd'hui content
il ya des mères qui sont obligés de
signer des textes
dans le nouvel obs ça grogne de partout
et là à vous écouter alors là tout d'un
coup c'est parfait et ça va ça va sortir
dans bah non il ya au bout d'un moment
il faut encore un sujet linge au
contraire il a une vision encore une
fois en termes de méthode et sur le
systémique est extrêmement clair prenons
l'exemple des 30 mai stage 30 ou si
aujourd'hui on est aujourd'hui les ados
diversité de la vie voilà qui
aujourd'hui a mis sur la table que à la
rentrée donc pour la prochaine rentrée
scolaire il y aurait 30 mille stage qui
seraient proposées pour les quartiers
populaires c'est par un modèle il ya des
réflexions de faire des années pour le
coup sûr la politique de la ville soit
on essaie de donner plus à ces quartiers
parce qu'ils ont moins
c'est en effet de voir comment les
réintégrer dans quelque chose de global
effectivement et ça peut être
éventuellement d'autres mesures mais là
on ne vois pas du tout où ça rend venir
vous savez revenir mais qui a déjà
résolu jusqu'à maintenant le problème
des stages de troisième dans les culs pv
non non non c'était il y avait déjà
extrêmement de beaucoup beaucoup
d'expérimentations départementale si on
prenait l'exemple du 93 que vous preniez
tout à l'heure c'est mis en place depuis
quatre ans et cette histoire là donc non
c'est pas c'est pas une nouveauté non
par contre ce qui est nouveau et kehl à
jour joint en termes de logique
systémique
c'est très clair de la part du président
c'est chacun pour soi
on donne une chance à chacun et si vous
échouez c'est de vous tracer parce que
et d'accès quinze personnes autour de la
table sur des sujets d'emploi s'est pas
manifestée en plus que rien et il ya
certainement pas chacun pour soi je peux
vous assurer que amener des entreprises
autour de la table et les renvoyer par
rapport à la responsabilité parce que la
responsabilité sociale des entreprises
ça veut dire quelque chose
c'est pas rien ne s'est pas rien on
passe quand même de l'accès au droit
pour tout ce qui est une valeur
républicaine a une chance pour chacun
ça veut dire que on leur pose très
clairement la phase la question
individuelle de la réussite ou de
l'échec c'est pas à la hauteur de la
république française quand dans le ces
quartiers là madame parlait du taux de
pauvreté c'est 43%
de population dans les culs pv qui sont
en dessous du seuil de pauvreté aux
citrons fera plus de chômage chez les
jeunes selon le plan borloo soit la
république
la france prend en considération cette
question là parce que si on veut
regarder le territoire de saint quentin
en yvelines ces huit à neuf quartiers
qui sont occupées v
ces cinq villes sur ces scènes quartier
précisément quatre villes et plus de 31
ans il habite angers les schistes
certains quartiers sont en veille parce
que le gouvernement dernier les
quartiers c'est le cas et je trouve
qu'il faut quand même les comptes et à
un moment donné si ces quartiers là on
ne les aide pas à regagner le niveau du
droit commun pour toutes les villes mais
c'est l'ensemble du territoire qui en
pâtit et c'est la même chose pour la
france si on ne donne pas vous parliez
de la seine-saint-denis si on redonne
pas véritablement beaucoup plus de
moyens pour la seine-saint-denis et on
va se dire les choix que les gens c'est
de la réussite actuelle qu est-ce qui
remercia tivo 6 du président de dire
qu'il ya beaucoup d'énergie de choses
qui se passent très bien danser dans les
banlieues dans les quartiers défavorisés
il faut donner la parole aux acteurs
locaux ceux qui vivent le quartier tous
les jours est ce que cette initiative là
pour porter des projets qui pourront
après entraîner des financements est ce
que cette position là n'est pas n'est
pas aussi intelligent et plus ça c'est
typiquement la logique de la politique
de la ville depuis le début qu'on a pas
par deux pays et a devancé relation à
ben oui parce que le président s'était
dit aujourd'hui la logique même de la
politique de la ville et celle là depuis
le départ effectivement c'est cette idée
qu'on va penser une nouvelle forme de
politique qui part du boc ont va faire
participer les habitants ça ça date
pourtant c'est alors selon vous en tout
cas c'est compliqué mais mais au moins
voilà mais c'est pas quelque chose de
nouveau
simplement effectivement il faut que sa
rencontre d'autres choses il faut que ça
s'intègre dans autre chose je vois pas
comment on peut simplement dire que ça
va suffire de mettre des bonnes volontés
en bas qui vont forcément qui ont besoin
de toutes façons de square d'être
coordonnés de se coordonner
moi ce que je disais tout à l'heure
c'est qu'il ya des inégalités de
population il ya aussi des inégalités
entre les territoires
est ce que l'on cherche à
s'attaquer entre guillemets à cette
question là sans le vois pas du tout où
enfin on a l'impression c'est pas le
territoire qui va spontanément avoir
envie de soutenir le territoire d'à côté
par exemple
donc on voit bien qu'il ya des charges
décennie qui peut à un moment donné est
de plus en plus si vous regardez la loi
élan énormément d'éléments qui re met en
avant les opci justement pour essayer de
jouer cette carte de solidarité sur 50
il faut pas revendiquer tout et son
contraire
t'as qu'à un moment donné la commune
elle a son rôle à jouer et alain maillon
essentiel dans ces sujets là il faut il
faut pas s'en éloigner
par contre cette solidarité au niveau
d'une agglomération comme était de
communes enfin peu importe le format
juridique qui existe doit doit être
présent doit être présent moi je les ai
vus la semaine dernière j'ai eu la
chance d'aller participer à la première
promotion de notre force 3 donc la
grande école du numérique là qui est
lancée par saint quentin en yvelines
qu'initiative assez extraordinaire il y
avait quinze personnes dans cette
promotion je peux vous dire que j'avais
les quinze discrimination qui existent
dans tous les quartiers elle était là
mais ça va être quoi la force de
multiplier les acteurs et les mettre les
uns à côté des autres et ben ils avaient
des forces qui étaient là mais il y
avait aussi fasc était là il y avait
mosaïque était là et on a pu parler
d'emploi et de formation
si les jeunes et les moins jeunes ce qui
n'est pas que des jeunes d'ailleurs dans
cette formation sont uniquement à mener
en termes de formation et qu'au bout il
n'a pas les entreprises qui les
regardent et qui comprennent
l'information qu'ils ont fait ils
trouveront pas de boulot donc la
déception et sera là c'est pas le tout
de financer une formation si elle doit
pas d'emploi dès le début de la
réflexion on dit cette formation est une
idée géniale on les amène vers le métier
du numérique et nous on apporter
entreprise avec notre projet
immédiatement
est-ce qu'il faut qu'ils aient un
débouché emplois derrière sinon la
déception continuera les jeunes qui font
la guerre anti jeunes c'est la même
chose vous les amener dans la garantie
jeunes à la sortie de la garantie jeunes
qu'est ce qu'il ya
rien ne les entend de nouveau c'est par
rapport à peut-être et encore haussé par
rapport aux entreprises j'entends une
forêt insistons sur les entreprises mais
en tout cas l'idée de partir d'en bas
d'avoir des échanges ensemble refaire la
ville c'était le rapport du debout au
sujet duquel année mais au début des
années 80 si je me souviens bien
donc ça c'est très anciens alors
peut-être qu'on mettait moins
d'insistance effectivement sur la
dimension des entreprises
mais moi je ne vois pas comment elle les
entreprises j'allais dire elle pourrait
venir comme ça s'il n'y a pas un
engagement y compris de l'état plus plus
fort et
apprécié l'engagement par rapport aux
entreprises deux choses c'est important
de choses modification du code civil
l'intégration de l'objet social dans le
code civil dire qu'on va demander aux
entreprises d'écrire une raison d'être
au sens développement du social de deux
messi mais là c'est extrêmement la
résidence des vingt ans et lui-même
écrit la fa qui a modifié le côté tison
au sérieux les annonces nous l'annoncent
vient des fêtes
il faudra aussi du temps pour voir si
c'est l'américaine au delà au delà on
est dans l'eau parce que là on est dans
le coma ou plaire là on parle de la
politique de sting une décision
entreprises du sbf 120
mais j'y arrive là c'est l'une des
questions quand même qui se pose c'est
la question de l'emploi
et je suis désolé c'est pas dans la
politique de la ville que se pose la
première question de l'emploi
c'est dans le droit commun c'est-à-dire
qu'il n'ya pas de politique d'emploi n'y
a pas de politique industrielle sérieuse
dans dans ce pays on patine en termes de
développement économique l'emploi ne
reprend pas et en tout cas les emplois
qu'ils reprennent sont des emplois
précaires et les premiers et je dirais
même les premières îles touchées
ce sont les femmes dans les quartiers
populaires c'est à dire que si on n'a
pas l'ensemble de la politique qui
reprend des couleurs qui s'attaque au
véritable problème de société qui sont
l'emploi la question du service public
partout parce que là on en vous n'en
parlez par la question du service public
mais les merengues
oui sauf que les quartiers les quartiers
populaires de plus en plus c'est le
service public et des tapas que mal les
collectivités sont bien obligés de
palier mais c'est bien les services
publics d'état qui disparaissent au fur
et à mesure des quartiers et là il ya un
vrai souci là il ya un véritable souci
et là on ne retrouve pas les tanks
soyons concrets c'est vraiment soyons
concrets nous sommes sur un territoire
nous avons une université c'est bien
placé pour le savoir
juste avant l'été voilà juste à côté
nous avons des culs pv il ya 500 jeunes
qu'ils soient inscrits dans le listing
de pôle emploi
si on n'avait pas lancé le projet qui
s'inscrit dans la politique d' emmanuel
macron du 22 mai si on n'avait pas lancé
le projet 1000 jeunes les entreprises
s'engagent le croisement des fichiers de
des jeunes qui sortent de l'université
qui habite en occuper v qui n'ont pas de
boulot alors qu'il devrait en avoir
n'aurait jamais été fait donc quand je
veux dire mettre les acteurs autour de
la table c'est faire ce travail là qu'on
a oublié par le temps parce que voilà
pour
emploi et dans son secteur effet 80% du
travail avec les gens qu'ils rencontrent
au quotidien
l'université dans son activité et fait
son quotidien les entreprises de saint
quentin en yvelines font du business et
cherche pas à les voir pour l'emploi ou
l'université si vous les mettez autour
de la table on recommence à créer de la
valeur en croisant des informations pour
eux c'est le travail de terrain c'est
celui là pour recentrer le rien le débat
et fait des choses nouvelles et on fait
des choses des résultats on réussisse et
six jeunes ont douze mois au moins c'est
à dire ah non c'est vrai je vais
peut-être vous mettre d'accord tout de
suite est ce que aujourd'hui à une
batterie de mesures est ce que la
priorité numéro un c'est la lutte contre
le chômage et notamment le chômage des
jeunes dansaient dans ces quartiers est
ce que c'est ça s'il y avait une chose
sur laquelle il fallait accélérer plus
que la rénovation urbaine plus que
peut-être les services publics est ce
que c'est la lutte contre le chômage des
jeunes marie doré sont alors moi j'ai
travaillé sur la précarité j'ai toujours
dit que shauna je n'étais pas la seule
question d'accord ils sont liés et puis
le problème de la précarité est
importante aussi parce que en
particulier pour les jeunes
l'emploi est très souvent un emploi qui
vous sous forme de stages voilà
d'emplois précaires etc qui n'en est pas
un c'est principalement mais pas du tout
sorti continental mondiale mais voilà
donc arrêter de deux lampes aujourd'hui
de remettre sur n'importe quel emploi
mais je suis pas convaincu par sa
bascule en tout cas ça ne permet pas de
lutter contre la pauvreté par exemple
c'est le fameux problème des
travailleurs pauvres
quand on met l'accent uniquement sur la
dimension emploi à n'importe quel prix
je devrais dire les banques créent des
travailleurs pauvres c'est ce qu'on a vu
historiquement nantes là il faut
absolument relié avec les autres
dimensions aucune politique d'emplois
aidés par les emplois francs qui vont
directement aux entreprises
il ya plus justement et dieu sait si
vous avez tous créé après le sujet on a
concentré les emplois aidés sur quatre
secteurs d'activités points mais la
question n'est pas sur les employés des
six parce que compte encore des
travailleurs pauvres c'est exactement ça
c'est tout à fait vrai les dans les
quartiers il ya une tentation enfin
j'veux dire apprécié parce qu'on a fait
avec les moyens qu'on avait si on
raisonne pas on va amener à l'emploi
quel que soit le type d'emploi et
pourquoi pas un emploi aidé je suis
entièrement d'accord avec vous on
continue à biaiser le système parce
qu'ils diront jamais à l'emploi réel le
cdi je veux dire voilà comment chaque
terme et qui sinon
dans l'économie réelle et là je peux
vous assurer que les choses elle tourne
complètement sur la question économique
le gouvernement a plutôt choisi la
finance la question pourrait peut-être
se poser sur l'industrie sur l'économie
réelle sur l'emploi 15 elle assure la
formation s'est pas n'est pas ce qui
n'est pas délocalisable
je vous parle pas de formation je vous
parle véritablement d'une relance
économique d'une relance de l'emploi
mais juste pour répondre à votre
question de est ce que c'est la priorité
d'emploi
je rejoins c'est ce que dit madame si on
ne comprend pas que les quartiers
populaires non pas des problèmes qui
n'existent pas ailleurs tous les
problèmes de la société tu te retrouves
dans les quartiers sont construit nous
sommes donc c'est une somme de problèmes
et il est inimaginable de régler d'un
côté par exemple le service public et
leur maillage du service public partout
on pourrait parler de la sncf par
exemple mais ça sera un autre débat et
puis d'autres d'autres services publics
c'est inimaginable de penser remettre un
peu de services publics partout pour
qu'ils soient plus performants et
répondent aux besoins sans traiter de la
question d'emploi et des questions
durable de l'emploi durable et non
précaires comme ce serait inimaginable
de ne pas repenser la question du
transport de repenser ses toutes ces
questions de d'accord je voulais une
dernière question peut-être d'ordre
philosophique si je peux me permettre
est ce que finalement l'enjeu malgré les
mesures ce n'est pas d'entamer une
révolution des esprits le regard qu'on
porte sur cette jeunesse le regard que
nous tous médias politiques
institutionnelles on porte sur sur les
quartiers de la ville est-ce que c'est
pas ça le plus important que les
entreprises jouent le jeu que chaque
citoyen jouent le jeu qu'on fasse tout
ça un effort aussi sur sur par et des
stéréotypes des clichés qu'on peut avoir
est ce qu'il n'ya pas aussi c'est ton
jeu là au delà des démesures de l'argent
dont on parle tout le temps je me tourne
vers avancé le chercheur 30 secondes
chacun pour l'instant encore une fois le
ressenti que j'ai moi de ce monde là ça
a plutôt été un grand abandon donc c'est
plutôt raté
de ce point de vue là parce que voilà on
peut pas dire simplement peut-être un
peut-être quand chacun dans son coin of
cobra mais non mais
aussi cette idée chaque reprise j'étais
vraiment surprise et de président de la
république doit rappeler que ce sont des
quartiers qui appartiennent à la
république qu'ils vont être traitées
autant que possible comme tout le monde
et que ce n'est pas toujours le cas
effectivement
et puis que on va faire tout ce qui est
possible pour quand ils sont en dehors
les réintégrer donc c'est la csn le
discours là il a manqué quelque chose à
mon avis après est-ce que les méthodes
qui sont prises le permettront je ne
sais pas mais là dans le discours moi je
pense qu'il est passé à porter pour
chacun votre tour clementé appelé chair
très rapidement c'est pas une question
d'image de sur les quartiers populaires
c'est que là aujourd'hui
au delà du fait qu'il ya un je trouve
moi un véritable mépris des quartiers
populaires et de leurs habitants mais
c'est effectivement au c'est pas une
question d'image il faut juste permettre
aux gens qui vivent dans les culs pv de
pouvoir vivre décemment
comme tout le monde comme tout citoyen
de la république française ce qui veut
dire la question de la solidarité
nationale c'est sans doute cette année
fort haussier qui peut être fait par
tout un chacun mais c'est du rôle de
l'état et c'est l'état qui est attendu à
cette place-là guide ce qui guide notre
politique c'est la lutte contre les
discriminations il faut que chacun à son
niveau que ce soit à l'école dans la
santé dans l'emploi la lutte contre les
discriminations soit l'objectif est
quand on veut mettre les entreprises
face à leurs responsabilités c'est par
rapport à ce sujet là pas en disant
parce que tout le monde discrimine sans
le faire exprès mais en tout cas en
accompagnant en aidant à comprendre
pourquoi la lutte contre les
discriminations ça n'est pas si
compliqué que ça finalement
merci à tous les trois c'est la fin de
7,8 le débat prochaine émission jeudi
prochain à 18h30 en direct d'ici là vous
retrouvez cette émission replay sur tv
78 points comme et sur l'application tv
60,18 merci à tous
[Musique]